- By the time we reach
these, we're just like,
"This is the best!"
(midtempo rock music)
- This one smells like a fraternity floor.
- It smells a little fruity.
- Ooh I like that one.
- Very watery.
- This is fine.
It's kinda like, fruity.
- Has a little bit of a
pineapple juice taste.
- This one, I kinda wanna just chug it
and then flip-cup it.
- Done and...
Done.
- [Man] Smells like apple juice.
- [Woman] Naw dude, smells like honey.
- Slightly darker.
Which is a sign of fanciness.
- Mmm.
- Oh!
- Ooh!
- Yeah, right?
- Mm hmm.
- There's like, a sourness
to it.
- Are we supposed to
swish it and spit it out?
(gargles)
- [Woman] This is scary beer!
Scary beer.
What is it?
(bleep) water. (laughing)
No!
- I love dark beer!
- I don't like dark beer.
- Shut up.
- That tastes like chocolate.
- It kinda tastes like bacon.
- Ooh, too coffee.
- Yeah,
tastes a lot like coffee.
But it does the opposite thing.
- This is intriguing me.
- This is pretty good,
it's a little heavy.
- Probably an oatmeal stout of some kind
or a chocolate stout.
- I had oatmeal the other day.
And it looked nothing like this.
- [Woman] Smells kind of like chestnuts
or like walnuts or something.
- Smells like a men's bathroom.
- Ugh!
It looks like pee!
Why would you say that?
- This is a different flavor.
- I'd be down for this.
- This definitely tastes
like a really old beer.
Like an ancient beer.
- Is this a sea urchin beer?
- Oh it does taste kind of like the sea.
- Keep 'em comin'!
- [Man] Oh yeah!
- [Woman] This is college.
- [Man] Yeah.
- This is concert beer.
- Smells like a sticky floor.
- I'm smelling this and
I'm getting good memories.
- It's a little bitter huh?
- It's bitter.
- It's like beer pong beer.
- This is like,
mistakes but ones you don't regret.
- The more you drink,
the better it tastes.
- I know what this is.
This is a pilsner.
- Smells like broth.
- This is from the Czech Republic.
I'm calling it now.
- I really hope that
it's not a pilsner.
- [Man] Smells good.
- [Woman] Smells fragrant.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Woman] Smells like,
smells fruity and flowery
all at the same time.
- I don't know what this is.
It doesn't taste like
any of the other beers.
- This one's probably my favorite so far.
- I know nothing.
But this seems to be
a higher quality beer.
- The more I drink it, the more I like it.
- Yeah but that's probably
'cause you're getting drunk.
- This is a juicy beer.
- (laughing) Please
don't describe anything
as juicy ever again.
- Juicy.
- Ugh.
- [Man] This one smells
like a baseball game.
They all kinda smell like...
- They all
smell like baseball games. (laughing)
- Ooh, this one's Mexican for sure.
- This is...
- Like when you know it'll
taste good with a lime,
it's generally Mexican beer.
- Right.
- I like it, it's really refreshing.
Really nice.
- This tastes like weed!
- I'm not mad at this one either.
- No
- That smells like weed.
If you walked in and you smelled that
that would be marijuana.
- [Woman] Smells like cider.
- [Man] Woah.
- [Woman] Cider, dude.
- This is interesting.
This tastes a little like wine.
- It's a little bit
stronger, you can tell.
- This one tastes like Dove soap.
- (laughing) He's right!
- I really like
this one actually.
- This is like, fruity.
- This is like an API.
- IPA?
- Uh, AP...
- India?
- Yeah!
- You guys rock!
- Dude, you guys are awesome!
- You guys have the best
food and the best beer.
- Hey!
What up Peru.
- Here in Ireland we like bacon beer.
- Ahhh.
- It's from India.
Indians, you know how to make your beer.
- Ooh, what up Peru.
- Oh!
That's why I have the good memories.
(bleep) I love Corona.
- That's the one we said,
feels like we went clubbing with that one.
- I did go clubbing with this one.
- Yeah, Argentina!
- Is that the juicy one?
- Yours is Corona.
You thought it was a pilsner, right?
- Yeah.
- It's not.
- It's as if something
has impaired my judgement.
- India?
Way to go!
They have a lot of spices.
That was the more flavorful one.
- Ireland, I already knew Guinness.
Guinness, you're an old friend.
- I like beer.
- It wins.
Thank you.
- Yay beer!
Yay world, keep drinking, keep having fun
and be safe.
- I think Curly got the burps
(belch)
- Sorry they stink.
Aww man I got a deep burp coming
- My burps always smell.
- Wait I wanna smell
it, give it to the Lord.
Give it to the Lord.
- It always smells like salami.